thanks for coming
my session so
for the next 60 minutes or so I'm
about developing native Android
applications using react native now
before we get started let me try to
understand your your your background how
many of you are actually mobile
developers you write mobile apps okay so
for all those who put up your hands how
many of you are actually Android
developers okay and how are the rest I
phoned and that's why you're here
yes so for those of you who actually put
your hands up
you are Android developer what languages
what tools do you use to write your
android apps android studio java and how
many of you how many of you have
actually try react native ok only one
and ok ok so that's good so for the next
60 minutes you believe whatever I say
right so okay so now my name is Wei Ming
so I I come from Singapore so I have my
own training business it's called
developer learning solutions so I
basically focus on mobile development so
in particular iOS Android development
and in in more recent years I've also
been dabbling with Python machine
learning so and so forth
so right mobile is still something that
gets me really excited so okay so let's
dive into the agenda for the next six
minutes so first of all I wanna get you
started with react native so I think
most of the audience here are already
familiar with react so that needs no
introduction so react native is actually
born out of react so if you know react
you should be pretty familiar and
comfortable with react native so I will
explain to you anyway so I will give you
some motivation of why you want or you
should use react native and hopefully at
the end of this session for those of you
who have been using Java and Android
studio you should kiss your java goodbye
and say okay let's embrace JavaScript
and start writing our react native
mobile apps using react native hopefully
and I'll show you some really cool
features of react native call live
reload and hot reload
how many of you are have actually heard
of this two terms okay so kind of of you
okay so and I will talk about how to
actually perform some of the common
tasks for mobile development using react
native so for example if you're coming
from the Xcode background Android studio
background and you want to move into a
new development environment I think the
first question is you always ask
yourself okay so what's the language was
the language that I am going to use and
how do I do this how do I do that so for
example how do I actually perform
navigation how do I create a application
how do you actually get the location of
my device how do i display a map so and
so forth so I'm going to answer that
questions in this session how you can
actually achieve all this common
functionality is using react native and
I'm going to show you something that's
really really cool life updates using
this thing call could push now if you
have been doing mobile development you
know the pain so in the past you spend a
few months creating your applications
and then when you are finally done you
upload the application to App Store or
to Google Play and then what happens
next
so Apple typically takes about two weeks
to approve your apps all right and then
when your apps got approved I think
that's the happiest moment in your life
for those of you who have actually
deploy apps before do you agree with me
when your app when you when your first
app gets a proof on the App Store that
is the happiest moment in your life
don't tell your wife this your wife
wouldn't agree now what is react native
now before I go to the base react it let
me just complete this so once you have
actually gotten your your apps are proof
on the App Store so you are so excited
your users are all using your apps and
then suddenly somebody say there's a bug
in your app and you say oh okay let me
fix the app and then you update the app
you reload that to to App Store and then
apple says okay we will reveal your app
we were
and other five days to approve your apps
and then it's a gosh so in the next five
days that's the most painful period of
your life
so using code push you don't have to do
that
as soon as your application using react
native is actually deploy onto the
user's device you could simply make the
changes upload your your changes to code
push and then you could actually write
some logic on the application so that
you can periodically check for updates
and then you can bypass app store when
it comes to updates but this is a little
bit of a grayish area so Apple may
reject your app based on this but most
of the time from what I heard
Apple is ok with this so I'll show you
demo later on so what is reg native it's
a JavaScript framework for creating
native iOS and Android apps so notice
that I focus on the word native so this
is a pure native app this is not an app
that works like your Cordova or your
ionic applications which is which have
hybrid applications this is a pure
native app you are a first-class citizen
on the platform so for this session I'm
going to focus on Android for my next
session I'll talk more about iOS so it
is based on react Facebook JavaScript
library for building UI and your native
apps are written using a mixture of the
following so JavaScript so if you are
sensitive to this word Java then you
shouldn't be here so we're gonna use
this language called JavaScript together
with CSS and I I think the good news is
that I think most of you are also web
developers ok so if you are web
developers CSS is something that you eat
for breakfast so this is no big deal and
then JSX
so jxx in in my opinion stands for
javascript extension so it's a
combination of javascript together with
xml so you're gonna see that later on
now using the combination of javascript
CSS and JSX
the react native basically translates
your new iMac up so your UI mock-up is
actually the three components and it
translates your UI markup to native UI
elements so that your app runs as a
native app sounds too good to be true
but don't worry about that
so why react native how many of you have
requirements from your customers that
says I want your app to be able to run
on multiple platforms iPhones Android
Windows Phone now forget about Windows
Phone
what other platforms are they what are
the mobile platforms are they BlackBerry
forget about blackberry I think we are
left with iPhone iOS and Android so how
many of you how many of you all have
this kind of requirements if your
customer says that oh I only want and
ROI
I only want I phone they're lying to you
tomorrow when your app is done you'll
come back to you and say hey this one
looks good on Android can I have it
running on iPhone okay so real native
allows you to write cross-platform apps
really really easily
now I think most of the folks in this
conference are Microsoft users or
Microsoft developers so you guys eat see
shop for breakfast so I'm sure you have
heard of this thing called xamarin
anybody started on xamarin projects okay
so how do you find a Marine it's all
right okay
how about a couple of rest those who put
out your hand okay nevermind you can
tell me privately now so so when I was
starting out on on react native because
I've been spending a lot of time doing
objective-c sweet programming on the
iPhone side and then I've been doing
Java on the Android studio site so when
I first started on react native I wanted
to see how effective this is
so I started out by building the NDC a
Sydney application to see to convince
myself that this is really good so I
took about two weeks from downloading
the JSON data trying to repurpose the
data and then try to understand the
various navigation models what other
things can do what are the things you
cannot do and I was pretty impressed so
and I wanted to be able to run my my
application on multiple platforms iOS
and Android so ultimately I think I
managed to to get 99% could reuse so
basically it's write once run everywhere
right sounds familiar
so now your apps retain the native look
and feel of each platform so your app is
pure native so that's why it looks just
like a native application and it is
really useful for testing you can use
live and hot reloading and you can
instantly see the changes in your app so
for those of you who are new to this
feature later on let me show you a demo
on this and it has got very good
community support now react native is
sort of like with open source so the
good thing about open source is that
when you have a problem you go to stack
overflow and that is a solution yes so I
always like to tell my friends real
programmers don't write code real
programmers go to stack overflow copy
and paste code yes but that's a little
bit unfortunate because today we live in
a very fast pace book
things are changing so fast and and most
of the time you are just copying and
pasting as long but I I think if you
pace with understanding I think that's
that's ok so whatever you need there's a
package out there that can satisfy your
requirement and as the saying goes
there's a package for that ok now and I
mentioned earlier early on there's this
thing called push that allows you to
have dynamic app updates so that is
something that is really really cool so
I'll show a demo to you later on
now how to install react native it
basically uses nodejs and NPM so you
could simply follow the instructions on
on Facebook via native page install this
and install this this - called watch man
so watch men will basically monitors and
observe your files and then um when they
are changes when you make changes to
your code you will automatically refresh
your your your emulators or your real
device so I'll show you later on now the
best way to look at a new platform is
true the traditional hello world so
let's show you a demo so so I have the
Android emulator already up and running
so I want to create a new application so
I'm gonna call my application hello NDC
so I simply do a react native in it
hello NDC and I can specify the version
of react native that I want to use so I
got some problems if the latest version
so I'm gonna fall back one 2d slightly
earlier version 0.44 the good news of
react native is that it's still very
very in it's very very early stage quick
question when was react native released
to the developers community anybody 2015
much so it's about two and a half years
or so the good news is that when you go
for interview your employer cannot
cannot ask you do you have 10 years
experience on react native [ __ ]
right so so I'm gonna create a hello
world application so press enter and it
will go here and create a bunch of files
if you're familiar with nodejs you know
that you have a node modules created
with all the packages our show you in a
moment so this guy is working very hard
and what happens here is that I this is
the folder this is the phone that I have
and hello NDC and I have a node modules
folder that contains all the modules
that your application is gonna use
and it's just going to create a few more
folders and a few more files okay I
think we are done now
so this is the basic setup of your
project so first thing first you have a
folder called Android so this is where
your Android studio project is located
so once you have created your react
native project you could actually use
Android studio open up this folder and
this is an Android studio project and
you can deploy as per normal
you have another folder called iOS and
this is where your Xcode project is
located so if I double click on this I
will see Xcode and then I have two very
important files index dot iOS dot J s so
this is the entry point of your iOS
application and this is the entry point
for my Android application so if I
double click on this guy and if you are
familiar with react this is nothing new
so I import my react and component from
the react framework and I import the
following from my react native framework
as well and I have a component and this
is my UI so I have a render method that
renders my UI my screen and in this case
here you look at this guy so this is
your and this looks like your HTML right
looks like HTML or for those of you who
are coming from the same rain it looks
like yours MO so and so in this simple
example you have very similar it this
looks very similar to HTML now in fact
this whole block here is called JSX JSX
so it's a combination of your xml plus
your javascript i'm going to show you
some example of JavaScript statement
within this block of code now so how
does this look like when I run this on
the Android simulator so let me just go
back to my
online let me see D into hello and DC
and let me just run this so to run this
I can I have two choices
I can either open up my Android studio
project deploy through there or I can
run it through the CRI I can do a react
native run Android so I'm gonna press
enter and it is going to start something
called the package manager so this runs
behind the scene and so let this run for
a while this guy is very busy compelling
my coat and trying to deploy this on to
the emulator here so okay
okay so far so good sometimes the
problem with open source is that if
everything works it's really really
beautiful but if something doesn't work
you pull your hair out you know so
that's why I observe that a lot of
developers have very short hair okay so
okay okay so it's installing undo my
emulator now cool okay there you go so
if I were to compare this with this guy
[Music]
can you see whatever you have here is
this yeah makes sense and you have a lot
of you have your style sheet that
defines your look and feel so I don't
think I need to explain to you guys the
style [ __ ] so now using your traditional
tools like Android studio so you make
changes on your code so let's say now I
want to change this to something else
I'll welcome to react native welcome to
my session what would you do you can
save this and then go to your Android
studio redeploy right so react native
you don't have to do that you just need
to save your code and there you go okay
now the reason why it does this is
because previously I've already done
what we call live reload so if I if I
were to to select this enabled live
reload so whatever thinks I change here
the moment I do a save it will
automatically update my application try
to do that on Android studio you cannot
do that easily
okay cha know you just need to start up
your emulator that's it if there's only
one and only one emulator it will
automatically deploy to the only one
Emily today's running or device so if
you if you shut down your emulator you
have only your device connected you will
deploy to your device automatically okay
okay now or you could if you were to
deploy this on the real device how do
you actually bring up this menu oops
sorry
so if you are running this on a real
device how do you actually bring up this
def menu so you have to when you deploy
this application under your real device
now first of all by default it will not
work when you deploy this on the real
device it will not work you need to
configure some settings but before we
talk about that let me show you how to
bring up this menu so once you deploy
your application on to your device you
simply take your device and shake it you
shake it this device will pop up so for
every new application that need point on
the device you need to shake your phone
so when I first started on this was
deploying this on my real device I was
shaking my phone and my wife saw me
doing this and she's hot I got a fit and
she said what happened to you why are
you always shaking your phone now okay
so this is your hello whoo now look at
this look at this guy so this is what we
called the package manager so the
packaging manager is always running
behind the scenes so whenever you reload
or you make some changes to your to your
- for example let me just make some
changes welcome to my session and I
saved this the package manager will
actually look behind the scene recompile
and send the updated UI back to my
application so the package manager is
running as a
independent webserver listening at port
81 80 81 so it's always listening behind
the scene now when you deploy this onto
real devices you need to do this you
need to go to their settings you need to
go to set your debug server and you need
to key in the IP address of your machine
followed by 80 81 okay if not you will
see the very famous red colored screen
you go to stack overflow you see all the
questions talking about this now so this
is my hello whoo
so so let me just run through this if
you want to slice I will put it up on my
on my website or if you email me I'll
send you the slides so that you can
actually look at this so you don't have
to worry about copying this so you said
you're a media manager you start the
emulator instance and then in the
project folder just do a react native
run and draw in any automatically one so
and then for real device coming a real
device to your computer and then run and
draw it and you shake your device to
bring up the - menu and configure your
server host so this is what what it
looks like so def settings debug server
host enter your IP address and then
that's it and then reload and your
application will now be running on your
Android device so this is how you books
behind the scene so react native
basically takes your your coat and then
it bridges your coat to the respective
platform so at this moment you have
support for I wear support for Android
but what I recently read was that some
other companies have actually agreed to
support react native one company in
particular Microsoft it's talking to to
Facebook to support their applications
not Windows Phone I think maybe
Universal Windows platform or something
like that another country another
company Samsung Samsung is also talking
to Facebook twos to
Facebook to support their TVs I believe
how many of you actually use Samsung TVs
okay okay and you have a camera you know
you know no TV okay there are mine now
you read about all the security flaws
Weaver okay okay okay so when you go
back tonight it's good to for you to buy
a lg tv I'm just joking
so so for really cheap in this case they
take the view element here they will
basically convert this for four to two
into UI view for iOS and then you'll
convert this into the view element four
for Android so so this is how ebooks
behind the same very similar in concept
to xamarin for those of people are
familiar with is a marine now react
native brings us closer to to this
phrase that you you I'm sure you heard
of this in 1995 unless you were not born
in 1995 write once run everywhere right
but I think if you are a developer you
are very familiar this right once debug
everywhere correct
where were you in 1995 three three years
old debugging and you saw this this
fellow right Duke the Java Duke the the
silly mascot that keeps on jumping
around you know that was in 1995 when
they release this thing called Java
applets suddenly you can make your but
your webpages bounce so I was a
third-year student finishing my studies
and we heard of this thing called Java
applets we were so excited so they
finally you can make your webpages
bounce and then me and my field friends
we started a company and we went around
telling companies that hey we can now
make your webpages bounce and then the
companies just look at asset and then so
but so
my company didn't do well so that's why
I'm here today
okay so now JSX
javascript extension so you can combine
your new iMac up with JavaScript so this
is one example I have my UI which is XML
and then I have my coat which is
JavaScript now when you look at this
what's the first thing that comes into
your mind
to me the first thing that reminds me
this reminds me of is ASP you know we
have a ton for this spaghetti code it
seems like we are back to square one so
we are back to the stage where we have
UI plus code but this is not that bad as
spaghetti code in an asp so so now Jay X
will make your life really really easy
in react native you don't strictly have
to use JSX but if you don't use JSX your
life would be a little bit miserable so
you look at this so I have a view
element and within my view element I
have a touchable opacity and I have a
button so basically this means that I
want to have a button that is touchable
now if I don't write this way using JSX
my code is going to look like this
purely JavaScript okay so it's it really
depends on you depends depending on the
your chest roll for pain so now react
packager that's what one day I tell you
just now
so the react package basically converts
the source code of your app and it
basically what it does is that it
transpires your code from JSX do eggman
script it converts your code from Eggman
script 2016 also known as es7 and Eggman
script 2015 also known as es6 to es5 now
all those Java developers are crazy
people with all the different namings
you
my script 2016 and then they renamed it
as es se f7 they can seems to pick up
their mind so so so basically that's the
use of the react packaging manager and
it's served your destination code at the
following URL now so this is what
happens behind the scene so early on
when I was running my hello NDC
application the react packaging manager
is actually serving my coat at this URL
and if you were to use a browser point
to this URL you actually see a one whole
bunch of JavaScript and this the one
that's being sent to your application
and your application you know your
Android studio application would take
this code and Bui okay let's let's move
on now
for laying our elements so react native
users flexbox for laying out components
those of you who are using Android
studio you typically layout your UI
using things like linearly our relative
layout and then lately they have this
thing called constrain Liao sauce nebula
yes no and and this is dunno who's this
guy Jackie Chan I know you guys love him
I don't but anyway let me just cut out
that portion now so flexbox basically
offers the following properties to help
you lay out your your views so things
like flex direction justify content
align items so let me just show you a
very quick basic tutorial on flexbox and
we can get moving
so basics are flexbox so I have a view
and within my view I have another view
and my first view my container view has
got this container style so it has got
justified content center align items
center and then it has got breakdown
color of this and then within my
container view I have another view with
80 high 80 and the background color is
actually blue so imagine how hot would
that UI look like me I guess okay just
imagine this in your head do you do you
get what I have so because I have a view
container I have another view so 80 80
center center so so there's a basics of
flex box now flex Direction one more
example
so imagine again in your head so I have
the container and now instead of having
one children I have two more children's
so I have two more 8080 and then
blue how does it look right now stack
this way or this way on top of each
other vertical by default all items in
the container arranged vertically you
get this okay so one more so this time
Rao same setup but I want to change my
Flex direction I want to set it to row
so this time Rao it looks this way okay
sizing I can use this Flex attribute so
I have flex : 1 flex : 1 flex : 1 and my
direction is roll now tell me how is
this going to look like before I show
you answer for the tree it will so even
you would distribute the size equally
because each one says flex 1 so think of
this as ratio okay so by specifying flex
1 each view will take all the available
space because there are 3 of them they
have to share and so in this case flex :
1 will cost the with attribute to be
ignored even though you have way with
attribute up there it's ignored one more
so this time Rao I change it to column I
will display in in column form maximum
with how is this going to look like so
now I'm switching back to flex Direction
row and for the first view I want to
have the maximum with 90 and then the
rest doesn't have to
the next wave attribute so it's going to
look like this so basically it's a said
the first view max with 90 okay and you
can no go no more than that and the rest
of the we've you guys go and split up
among yourself okay one more time flex
one two three so I think now is easier
to do yeah yeah so they're in the ratio
one two three right so in this case you
get something like this okay so
straightforward how many of you have
actually done iOS programming Xcode okay
Xcode users Auto layout right which is a
pain in the back next thing justifying
content uh-huh so so now I'm switching
the Flex direction back to column okay
and I am doing a justify content flex
start so can you imagine how it's going
to look right now so all the items would
be aligned to the top flex that okay and
so you you you specify flex a one for
the view containing all the three other
views so that you can occupy the entire
column so the first container the this
view itself actually occupies the entire
column and the justify content attribute
indicates how its children should be
justified so flex start means position
it at the beginning of the container and
there is a there's a huge confusion
between this actually be called justify
content and align items so let me just
set the record straight so if the Flex
Direction is set to column
then justifying content affects the
vertical alignment and vice versa
okay so just just for your information
in case you come back to this slide
again you want to clarify the difference
between justify content and align items
flex n so position at the bottom space
around so I can have this thing called
space around and in this case it would
distribute the spaces so that each item
would have the same amount of space
between them I can also specify space
between and so this would specify that
all those items are distributed by the
same space in between them okay so so
far so good next thing we want to
discuss two important concepts now again
if you're familiar with react this is no
stranger to you and that is state and
prop so let me just define to you by
this state and what is problem by
showing you a very simple demo so what
are first of all props props are set by
the parent and their values are fixed
through down the lifetime of a component
so props are really properties of a
component so now first of all what is a
component so in react native everything
is a component so for example you have
you create your own custom button your
button is a component and so props are
basically the properties of that button
so when you try to add the button to
your UI what are the things you pass in
as attributes they are known as your
props your properties next thing States
are used to trigger re-rendering of your
apps UI so they are generally
initialized in the constructor of the
component and you call the set state
when you want to change the state and
read render your you are
now I think the state it's basically the
most difficult concept for people who
are moving from native development over
to react native because that requires a
little bit of different types of
thinking so let me show you a demo so
let me just put this one side and just
kill this guy okay let me just close off
this package manager okay so I have
another example that I have written and
let's just deploy this and when I'm
deploying this I'll show you the code
okay so it's called spinner and let me
open up my Android
okay so I'll show the court rest and
then it tell me what my code is doing
okay so it's pretty simple I have a
button called my button so my button
basically draws a view with a text and
it displays a label so essentially this
is my custom button and my custom button
is called my button quite a lame name
but but you know so in my main page for
my application I have the following so I
have a constructor I first of all say
that I have this dot state so and I said
that state's animating is equal to true
and button label is equal to the string
called stop animating and say and then
in my render I basically have the
following I have my button and I have
this thing called label so this label is
the attribute that you pass in to this
component call my button and so in this
case this label would be known as the
props of your component your properties
you following me and and my button has
got this label equal to the following
this dot state dot button label so if
you recall my initial text ball button
label is stop animating so let me see
whether okay so by default when it is
first loaded it is the spinner is
loading is spinning and my button has
got this event handler
call animate and when I click on this
button it will go to this function
called animate and I check if the button
label at this moment is equal to animate
set the labor to stop animating else set
it to animate and next thing once I'm
done I do a set state so in this case
initially my UI has got the following
state my button has got the following
label assigned to the state and the
activity indicator which is spinner
whether it is animating is set to this
particular state so when I click on this
button it goes to animate function and I
want to change the state the moment I
call this changing I call this function
called set state it would change the
value of the states that I specify here
and it would cost the render method to
be rendered again and this time Rao when
I click on stop animating it will stop
animating if I click on this it will
continue to animate ok so so this is the
the key challenge that you encounter if
you are coming from the traditional
Android studio a platform where you use
functions like 5 view by ID you get a
reference to that and then you change
the the caption of that button dot text
equals button dot set text blah blah
blah so so this is called state and
props okay so now that we have covered
the basics so let me talk about some of
the key or key constants so before you
actually take the plunge and move into
react native you want to know how do I
do certain things so I hope to answer
your questions in the next few slides
now this are the billion components in
react native all those that has got a
suffix of Android only works in Android
itself all those that has got a suffix
of iOS works only on iOS all the rares
are supposedly cross-platform so if you
are developing cross-platform
applications be sure to pick the right
components to make sure that it displays
correctly on both platforms so for
example you have things like image which
should work on both platforms and if you
for example if you use the date picker
iOS that unfortunately only works on iOS
but that's not the end of the ball so
I'll talk about that what happens if the
things that you need here they are not
listed in in this slide so just remember
the community support is really
fantastic whatever you need people have
that now the first thing that you
probably will are sustained okay I want
to display a list of items so in in
Android you can use the least view and
then you can for those of you who are
doing and draw you may also have
fragments so for for for displaying a
list of items you have two choices you
can either use a section list so for the
NEC application that I have for viewing
the agenda I use a section list section
list allows you to display section
headers so for each section headers you
can actually render what are the things
you want and then you can render all the
individual items you can also render
your separator if you want to draw a
line between items so you use something
called a section list okay now but if
you want to have a simpler way of
listing items without the need for
section headers you can use something
called flat list so the flat list is one
you will see you know and ECM when you
go to such four speakers so it's just a
list of items so pretty straight
next thing a lot of people are building
location-based services so you need to
know your users location so react native
comes with the Joe location API
so it's basically very similar to the
web-based geolocation API and you only
need to in the necessary permissions to
your iOS as well as Android projects and
then your application will be able to
get the users location so this is a
simple code of how how it looks like so
you use the navigator dot geo location
or get current position and then you use
the navigation Jo location don't watch
position so this would be fired whenever
a new location is obtained so in my
example here I want to change the state
of latitude and longitude so that I can
update my UI to reflect the latest
latitude longitude that I have obtained
next thing after you have gotten your
locations you want to be able to display
maps so this is one of the most painful
thing that I encountered initially so
but luckily that's the solution so if
you want to display maps on your Android
as well as iOS application the best
solution is to go to this component from
Airbnb so a B&B has got this react
native Maps component where you can
actually download install into your
application so generally this is how you
actually use the party components so so
this is the the way you to survive so
you are doing a relative application and
then you want to do something ah I can't
find that functionality natively so you
go to Google you search for a react
native component so you encountered this
react native Maps so the first thing you
do is CD into your project folder you do
an NPM install react native Maps
so basically you download that module
into your current project and then you
do a link link will update your Android
project your iOS project your Xcode
project
so that they have two required libraries
in your in a project so generally this
applies to most of the components that
you were encounter okay and for for the
react native Maps component it uses
Apple Maps for iOS and it uses Google
Maps for Android so for Android you need
to apply for the Maps API key which I
think most people are already familiar
with so this is how it looks like data
storage now most people use two ways to
store to persist data so in Android you
can use the secret light database if you
want to or you could use what's the way
that you in the API that you used to
store key value pairs in android let me
see whether you are really Android
developers well I say what's the API
that you use to store key value pairs in
Android share preferences right did I
say the wrong thing okay nevermind but
anyway so in Android we have this class
called shared preferences so which
allows you to store key value pairs very
easily so the equivalent of share
preferences in react native is a Singh
storage
so a Singh storage allows you to store
key value pairs into your storage
without needing you to worry about how
the underlying file system or database
book but if you want to do store
structured data using sequel Lite there
are a lot of components out there you
can use the react native sequel like
storage component again install that
into your project link that with your
project and then you can have access to
secret like database neck booking of
course your applications want to talk to
outside wall now in reality there are a
few ways to talk to the outside wall you
can use the fetch API which returns you
the a promise object so you can connect
to a URL get back the response convert
this to a JSON process the JSON file
update your UI whatever things you want
or for those of you who likes to use XML
HTTP requests it is also available in
react native and web sockets is also
supported and there are also third-party
modules like socket IO I'm sure you
refer to build socket IO that allows you
to connect to your back-end using
sockets navigation so when I was
building this this n DC application I
wanted a way to build a tab application
but at the same time I want to be able
to navigate to another page so this is a
pretty common UI architecture so for
navigation you can actually use react
navigation component so it's an
extensible and yet easy to use
navigation solution so let me show you a
very quick demo so I have built a very
simple application containing three tabs
news speakers schedule so on the first
page nothing fanciful on the second page
which is the speakers I have a button
here so if I tap on this button it will
navigate to the talks page and notice
that if I tap on the back button it will
return me back to this page ok so it's a
combination of tab pages + navigation
pages so let me show you how it looks
like so I'm gonna close this packaging
manager and then I'm using navigation
and then I'm gonna run this put this one
side and so let me just run through the
slice fest so it basically contains
three tabs news represented by news j/s
my javascript file speakers speakers yes
and this because it's going to navigate
to talks which is represented by Jas and
I have another tab called schedule
represented by schedule GS now so in
order to piece all the navigation
together I create a file called router
Jas so this is how it's gonna look like
so I create first of all what we call
stank navigator so I have the new stack
so my new stank only have one page and I
have my speaker's stank my speaker stack
has got speakers as far as talks and
then I have a schedule which only has
got one page and I put them together
using what we call a tab navigator
attempt navigator has got the following
so these are the items these are all the
tab pages so I have my new stack speaker
stack schedule stack and so the end
result of this is something like what I
have here so I have my news I have my
speakers I can swiped scheduled go back
if I click on this view talks I can
navigate back as well ok now and if I go
to view talks I will see this pitch now
earlier on I talked about this thing
called live reload
live reload basically means when I make
changes to my page it would
automatically be refresh on the device
or emulator there is one more term
called hot reload sometimes when your
app is deeply nested so you you navigate
to a lot of pages
live reload will not be able to update
your your navigated pages automatically
so what you need to do is you need to
make some changes reload your
application and then you navigate back
to the page again so hot reload
overcomes the limitation so let me show
you so I'm using this using navigation
and draw so this is the tox application
so top application
so I have my top page so my top page
corresponds to whatever I have here so
what I can do here is that I can go here
and I can say that I want to you know i
have previously and a bit that so i'm
going to disable and show you to you
again
okay so let me just show it to you again
and then my talks so and I'm going to
enable hot reload previously it was live
reload this time hot reload so I'm gonna
do a hot reload and so now when I go to
here I go to here look at this and I'm
gonna change this to my top page my
session page and when I'm save this it
will automatically do a hot reload and
you will change automatically okay so
like reloading is when it applies to the
main page of your application so for
example in your application you only
have one one pitch one page then live
reloading is really really useful but
then when in a more complex application
where you actually navigate into other
different pages then that's where hot
reloading comes in yes yes yes you wanna
sing a pitch as well as pages that you
have navigated okay so so that's pretty
cool so so that saves you a lot of time
so when I was developing this NDC
application I realized that oh I can
really save a lot of time
so in nobly when you use Android studio
or you use Xcode when I make changes you
have to deploy and then you have to test
it all over again but using live reload
and hot reload things are really really
that simple okay so that is hot reload
so okay and then finally in text or
Android j/s I just need to load from my
router and as in the tabs okay
one final thing that I'm gonna show you
dynamic updates so I mentioned about
code push earlier on so this is how code
push work so you are the developers it
looks cool right so so after you have
deploy your application to the App Store
or Google Play you want to make changes
what you need to do is you just need to
modify your code on your site the reason
why I have a ninja here is because you
can update your app without letting
Apple or Google knows so this is pretty
cool
so you write your mu make your changes
and then you pass it on to push and then
your application itself either you can
actually automate the the checking or
updates every half a day every day every
two days or you could actually ask the
user to press a button on the app to
check for updates if there are updates
download this over to the site refresh
the application and then you have to
leave this version of the latest version
of your app so so these are the steps to
do to use code push but let me show you
a demo nothing showing you a demo is
more fun right I just realized that I
did not plug in my power so we are left
with 11% but shut
I did the user will be prompted the user
be prompted with a dialog yeah okay so
so let me just close off this guy don't
wanna eat wait better to plug in my
power because I think this machine would
go to sleep in when it's less than okay
okay let me try my luck so okay and then
let me just try to deploy this guy okay
so I'm gonna deploy this application on
to my emulator let's move this one side
and so this is my application my dynamic
app let's make some changes to that
later on
okay let me just save some time here
while I'm deploying my could push
lightly it's quite a number of things to
talk about but I don't think I have
enough time but but let me share
something with you if you're trying to
build something fun there's something
called gifted chat have you seen have
you heard of this thing called gifted
chat if you are trying to build a chat
application you need to build a UI right
so no UI should look like this where you
can actually talk to somebody and then
you can receive a message from from
somebody so when I was building this
application this end is the application
I actually build this application for a
previous conference deaf teacher at
Canada so I incorporated this chat
feature into the app so this feature
would allow fellow participants of the
conference to actually talk to each
other so while you're sitting there you
can use my app to share with each other
and exchange opinions about this session
or whatever so but then I realized that
developers don't like to talk to each
other
when I deployed an app I realized that
nobody is using that fish functionality
so so for this particular app I I did
not include that so but but this is
something that's really really cool and
you don't have to get your hands dirty
on Beauty the UI somebody has done that
for you gifted chat if you go to google
your search for young native gifted chat
which is cross-platform it works for iOS
it works for Android and you have a very
nice chat user interface and you can
display pictures of the people who are
talking to each other and then you
combine this with socket I all you can
actually have a back-end server and can
do sockets programming so it's really
really cool anyway okay so my code push
is done so this is my application so
let's just imagine that this application
has been deployed to Google Play and I
want to make some changes so I go in I
make some changes save this and I go
back to my application here assuming
that I have already previously done all
my setup we've got pushed I simply need
to do this let me just show you the
c'mon
I have a command somewhere here no yeah
they go so I just need to do this code
push release react my dynamic app which
is the name of my application followed
by the platform Android enter and my
code will now be pushed to code pushed
so it will do the processing the
packaging upload this to the code push
server and what I have here on my
application here is that I have a button
to allow the user to check for updates
so I need power I need power where is
this is really anticlimax but but don't
don't worry I have one more session
after this where I'll be talking about
iOS it's almost the same same same stuff
so if you don't mind listening to my
jokes again you can always attend my
session but ok I hope I hope they did
not kill mine
but in any case so when I click on the
button check for updates it will first
of all check with code push to see if
there is a newer version of this app
available if no nothing happened but
then if there is a newer version you
will Pramod I log to ask the user do you
want to do you want to actually update
your application the user can say
install and then the application would
be updated with a new UI ok so if I run
out of time okay okay so so III think I
can't show it to you but if you if you
want to see this hang around I'll show
you I'll prove to you that you books ok
ok so I think we have wrong time I need
to rush over to the other side but if
you have questions for me please go
ahead and and I'll be around ok thank
you very much
[Applause]